as the true finale for The long-running
and beloved Indiana Jones franchise the
dial of Destiny ends on quite a
memorable note here's what it all means
Indiana Jones and the dial of Destiny
begins in 1944. Indiana's companion
basil Shaw and portrayed a train and are
on a mission to rescue treasure stolen
by Nazis some of these Treasures are
fake but one is the real deal half of
the anti-kithra or dial of Destiny
created by Archimedes and more
technologically advanced than anything
else that would be made for centuries
the film's main action occurs in 1969.
India is an old and jaded Professor
basil is dead and one of the Nazis from
the train Jurgen voller is a NASA rocket
scientist working on the moon landing
having conquered space baller now wants
to conquer time and is seeking out the
anti-chithera also seeking it is Basil's
daughter and Indy's goddaughter Helena
nicknamed wombat who re-enters Indy's
life after a long time away who is this
man I'm a Godfather when valer frames
Indy for the murder of two colleagues
the Asian archeology just once again
Dons is for Dora and embarks on a
globetrotting adventure to find the
other half of the anti-kithra before the
Nazis do wombats is both Indy's
companion and foil for their greed and
gambling debts bringing trouble young
Thief Teddy and diver Ronaldo help out
and eventually they find the Dial's
other half and Archimedes hidden tomb in
Sicily the Nazis come in hot on Indian
wombats Trail using information from the
kidnapped Teddy to find the tomb the
nature of the antecithra and Ballers
plan for it are revealed it can track
rips and time Waller intends to travel
back to Sicily on August 20th 1939 to
kill Hitler so the invasion of Poland
doesn't happen he believes that by doing
this the Third Reich can continue to
gain power without their ultimate defeat
in World War II the Nazis take Indie
hostage and fly their plane into the
rift fortunately wombat sneaks onto the
plane by a motorcycle and Teddy hijacks
another plane to chase them the
antecithra ends up taking everyone to
the siege of Syracuse in 213 BC as it
turns out this is the only time and
place the device can transport people to
the Nazis are easily dispatched amidst
the Greco-Roman battle the archaeologist
decides he wants to stay in the ancient
past but wombat brings him back home
where he reunites with his old love
Marion Ravenwood
at the calculations on the anti-kythera
work the way Waller plan the audience
would have seen an awkward scenario take
place beloved Nazi fighter Indiana Jones
would find himself in the position of
saving the life of Adolf Hitler though
his goal would be to stop bowler or
someone else from becoming an even more
powerful Nazi fuhrer even considering
how common would you kill Hitler debates
about the epics of time traveler this
would be a strange plot however even
before the anti-kythera leads them to
Roman times Indy suspects that there's
no risk of all or successfully reaching
his intended destination the reason
continental drift the map of the world
and Archimedes time was not the same as
the map that exists in 1969 and the
ancient Greeks didn't have any concept
of plate tectonics this prevented them
from predicting how geography subtly
shifts over time even if Archimedes had
knowledge of the future it would seem
pretty unlikely that he'd be able to
account for all of that
the creators of the dial of destiny were
clearly aware of the Intrigue of time
paradoxes while equally aware of their
potential to frustrate an audience this
becomes clear the moment Archimedes
finds a completed antikythera before he
even started building it however the
filmmakers thought ahead and made sure
to clean up most of the mess this
paradoxical Discovery makes as far as
paradoxes go the first has to do with
the notion that Archimedes is inspired
by his own work from the future if he
had started building the device only
after Nazis began falling from the sky
then the anti-kipra would have no origin
Point instead the movie makes it clear
that Archimedes had the idea for the
dial of Destiny Before Time Travel had
actually occurred the second Paradox has
to do with Archimedes possession of the
device the ancient mathematician manages
to get a hold of the dial and if he kept
it he would have effectively gotten the
device without actually having to invent
it in the first place the filmmaker
solved this problem when wombat takes
the anti-kithra from Archimedes telling
him that he needs to build the dial on
his own
do the mechanics of the Rifts in time
make scientific sense no they do not but
looking for scientific logic and an
Indiana Jones movie is a Fool's errand
magic exists in Indy's world and so do
aliens and the ability to survive a
nuclear blast inside a refrigerator the
time travel story here isn't a much
bigger stretch and it's the only huge
leap in a movie that arguably plays
things a bit too safe otherwise perhaps
in reaction to negative feelings over
Kingdom of the Crystal Skull getting a
bit too silly style of Destiny generally
feels a bit too restrained it gets
overly reverent towards Nostalgia and is
more than content to repeat the greatest
hits from prior movies the time travel
ending may be considered a nuke the
fridge moment but it is also the one
part of the new sequel that feels
genuinely fresh and bold it works
despite not fully making sense because
it's both entertaining and its absurdity
and emotionally fitting for a story
about an aging man so obsessed with the
past that he no longer feels at home in
the present Indiana Jones is
characterized as a man who feels out of
sync with the changing world around him
those days have come and gone perhaps
perhaps not this hippie neighbors know
him as the cranky old guy who tells them
to keep their music down the students
don't pay attention in class he's not
even excited about the moon landing
which you'd assume would Inspire at
least some Wonder though to be fair his
disinterest is Vindicated by the fact
that his old enemies are working at Nasa
now his only connection to the popular
Zeitgeist of the late 60s is invokly
opposing the Vietnam War unfortunately
he has a very tragic reason for that his
son mutt enlisted and was killed in
action the grief over mutt's death led
to the end of his marriage to Marion
traveling back in time to the same
battle he was desperately trying to make
his students care about is like a dream
for Andy he's willing to succumb to his
injuries and die in this dream because
he has always been in love with the past
and has grown increasingly lost in the
present he's getting on in years and
endured far more near-death experiences
than most people could ever imagine so
he said plenty of time to make peace
with the idea of his death on some level
he also feels that by staying behind
he's making a sacrifice that helps
Helena and Teddy get home safely Indy's
goddaughter of course won't tolerate
India's attempt at self-sacrifice she
clocks Indy right in the face and by the
time he regains Consciousness he's
already in his bed with his wounds
bandaged up he's initially upset about
having been saved against his will
claiming he has nothing left to live for
wombat presents a clear Counterpoint to
this by inviting over others who care
about him Teddy Salah and most
significantly of all Marion when Indy
and Marion have some alone time the
couple that broke up due to intense
emotional pain find each other again
through a little physical pain when
asked about his injuries Indy says that
everything hurts Marion says the same is
true for her but points specifically to
a place that doesn't hurt her elbow and
Indie kisses it she then points to her
collarbone which gets another kiss soon
they're kissing passionately this is fan
service Done Right the reversal of the
iconic kissing from Raiders of the Lost
Ark it also works perfectly as a
romantic happy ending
though we can't truly say for certain
that there won't be another sequel It's
all but certain this is going to be the
final Indiana Jones movie like James
mangold's prior Blockbuster Logan this
is a movie about an old man reflecting
upon his life and finding some sense of
closure unlike in Logan this closure
doesn't involve death which means it's
not an absolute franchise Ender but this
feels like it's meant to be a definitive
happy ending for Indiana Jones it's
interesting that between this and
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 Disney has
released two summer Blockbusters that
offer a firm sense of conclusion without
killing any main characters to give
their story a sense of finality with
Harrison Ford now 80 years old and the
studio having no interest in recasting
Indy the only plausible future for the
franchise would be spin-offs focused on
other characters in this universe PB
Waller Bridges Helena is a charismatic
enough new character that she could
certainly carry a Disney Plus show of
her own and there are also those
constant fan demands for kihui Kwan to
reprise the role of Short Round as an
adult
no time for love even then there are
rumors that Lucasville is now focusing
exclusively on Star Wars so even the
most promising Indiana Jones spin-off
ideas are extremely unlikely are you
sure
foreign foreign